Silk Road and it sold two billion
dollars worth of merchandise in only two
years okay so in 2014 my years may be
off in 2014 I think or 13 or 12 I went
to a party I met this guy - their name
Ross and he was pretty good looking and
tall so he definitely kind of stood out
because it was all nerds and we just
started talking and I was flirting with
this girl and he swoops in and takes her
home and I was like huh Ross it's us I
started talking to him and friend him
online and whatever what I do when you
win well I wasn't I was angry I don't
because like damn he was pretty charming
whatever became friends with him he
turns out he lived he lived down the
street from me well a few months later I
walked home and I walked by the library
that I live next door to and there's
always police there and I go home and
find out what happened and I had heard
of this thing called the Silk Road I'd
heard about this I knew about this for a
couple about a year - and I go home and
I look up what happened they go Ross got
it Ross Albright was arrested and for
being the founder of Silk Road and I was
explaining Silk Road if you don't know
what it is so Silk Road it's a it was
like eBay but for drugs and murder and
you could buy anything online and use
Silk Road and it sold two billion
dollars worth of merchandise in only two
years and Ross was the sole owner and
now if we look at Bitcoin price he had
roughly 10 billion dollars a Bitcoin
that he had made and it got seized or he
has it he's in jail what happened so
what happened was he was at his library
or at the library next door to my house
the Glen Park library and he was
upstairs on the computer doing deals or
whatever run the business and the feds
had been tracking him and he tried to
kill like he hired he did a couple hired
hits he's where he tried to get someone
killed and but the person on the other
end was an FBI agent so they went in
staged the murders and he did that
multiple time so he thought he had
killed three or four guys right and when
I got home I looked it up I was a holy
[__] that's raw
I know Ross he was this guy the whole
time and so you had hung out with him
before yeah it what was he a cool guy
did he say what did you ask what he was
just like just like just guy just
charming like did you know he ran I
looked him up on LinkedIn he said he was
a equities trader or like a bank like
some technically true yeah and like I
had friends on Facebook and he was like
hey everyone I'm selling my truck for
$2,000
turn I mean when he had tens of millions
of dollars a big coin and I go to the my
office the next day I go I try this guy
named Billy I go Billy did you hear
about this Ross guy the Silk Road thing
and Billy his father was Tim Draper
right and I go Billy this thing your dad
is talking about this Bitcoin thing and
he goes yeah I saw that that guy get
arrested he's buying a lot of it and I
was like should I and he goes yeah and I
was like well I don't know anything
about this Bitcoin thing so it but if
your your dad says to do it sounds good
to me so I went and bought a little bit
of it and then for each family member
that year in 2006 2013 I bought like
$200 a Bitcoin for each family members
present and they all laughed at me and
then a few years ago when I got the
$20,000 that each made like 5 grand
right and that was how I heard about
Bitcoin that's amazing and so so Tim
Draper ended up buying all the seized
Bitcoin I think it was like 20 million
dollars for the Bitcoin but I think it
was more than that dude I think it was
like in the hundreds I think was like
two hundred million dollars a bit
corners I don't remember
maybe I think his initial purchase at
the time was 20 million in a balloon to
billions I see okay and he bought it
from the government they bought it like
at a discount essentially to the market
right I think he paid 20 million but
this is all public and that is how I
found out about Bitcoin
[Music]